well at the moment the Internet is
enormous ly limiting in terms of the
capacity for innovation and and
variation I mean if you look at it
everything is pretty much the same
because of the constraints of the screen
and the you know the lack of the
peculiar things that happens to think
and paper and it is an enormous lis
limiting medium not to say that enormous
ly limiting mediums cannot produce great
work it can I mean if you stop to think
about making an etching when you realize
you have a plate of metal and you have
to make little scratches then you have
to fill a little ink and then you have
to put some damp paper on top of it and
given all of that you can still produce
the most extraordinary things you
realize that limitation materials and
scale and so on are not the central
issue except for the fact that when you
look at the electronic world you just
realize that the the amount of
repetition and images that are totally
determined by the medium itself tools
are tremendously powerful in changing
the nature of what you were wanting to
express there's a big difference between
doing a drawing of something with a
pencil on a sheet of paper and trying to
recreate that experience from existing
material that you assemble on a screen
and curiously
the pencil and paper turns out to be the
most potentially expressive medium for
reasons that are very complex to
understand so in truth there is no
really profound limitation on what you
do in terms of the imagination a scream
electronically but as it turns out the
material that you produce is so
dominated by the peculiarities of
electronic transmission that when we
look at it we see so many things that
look exactly the same it turns out to be
as is often the case first it feels like
the most enormously potential instrument
that any designer could have and then it
turns out to be something that so
dominates your thinking process that you
have to be very wary and very suspicious
of its power
well it's a bear development I mean I
and it exploits the innocent and that
very rarely produces good results I mean
it's not that from very beginning person
can't do good work or even something
about the fact that statistically if you
get a thousand pieces you're likely to
find one that is excellent at Philmont
my experience with all this sort of free
work and general calls for submission is
that they produce very low-level
responses it is also a real exploitation
of the innocent and people are so
desperate to find a way of becoming
visible that you can get anybody to work
for nothing
one of the curious things that happens
in the field is that because our
activity is linked to the arts and the
arts are not supposed to be concerned
with money after all money is impure
it's not fine there is strength amount
of inquiry about free work you can as I
probably have in the last two weeks you
can get 20 calls from people who want
and expect you to do something without
being paid for it because of visibility
or because you're not supposed to be
interested in money well that's not
exactly the case and so it is a I think
fundamentally exploitive you wouldn't go
into a butcher shop and ask for a pound
of steak without anticipating that you
would have to pay for it
well that's a complex question I mean it
the question of the degree of skill and
classicism and anyone's makeup is it
depends very much on context
and capacity how many people have
different attitudes it is possible to be
self-taught in any area but the issue of
whether somebody should have a classical
education depends very much on John Roth
for instance is it necessary to have a
classical education and music well if
that means to develop skills and
understanding about composition and also
to be able to play a piano or any other
instruments where you can express your
ideas I would say you'd be severely
limited if you couldn't do those things
I think the same thing is true in the
world of design I'm totally obsessed
with the idea of drawing as being the
fundamental tool and instrument by which
you understand what you're looking at
and there is no replacement for that the
idea of looking at something letting it
enter your brain transforming it moving
it down the neurological path to your
hands moving your hand to create
something that can be evaluated your by
your brain and correct it that iteration
that conversation between the mind the
hand it seems to me is the way we learn
what is real and the issue in the arts
very often is that question what is real
and the distinction between what we pre
imagine the world to be and what enables
it to enables us to see it with clarity
and understanding so there is nothing
that I know of or have experience that
enables us to engage the world better
than the act the draw
and be able to create form as we seen
you know people spend their entire life
trying to learn how to draw and then
after years and years of effort they
discover that they can successfully
replicate what's in front of them it's
the kind of drawing that appears in all
the art classes and all the studios as
people learn how to do it in the world
and then finally you learn that you can
represent what is in front of you
accurately at the same time you learn
that is not the point but that is only
the beginning of the real point which is
how to engage what is real